we watch
we listen
and we remember the past is already
written
the ink is dry
they have no idea what's going to happen
hey youtubers it's Charlie so surprise
surprise HBO looks like it dropped its
first teaser for Game of Thrones Season
six way unexpected so let's break it
down so it sounds like the Bloodraven is
talking to brand talking to him about
what happened in the past versus what
happened in the future now because we're
going to be talking about bloodraven
brand stuff just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen through season 5 on the
show now brands head out season 5 but I
just did a video on the Bloodraven
explaining how they recast Max von Sydow
so that's whose voice that you're
hearing you're also hearing brands voice
he says they have no idea what's coming
so obviously he's talking about the war
for the dodge talk about the white
Walker army but when the Bloodraven says
the past is already written just expect
to get some more Cersei type flashbacks
the fun thing though is that there are a
number of different ways to accomplish
that and without getting into too much
book stuff I'll say the weirwoods are
tied to the green Sears powers the
Bloodraven was the last greenseer till
brand came along the other big group
that shares this powers are the children
of the forest so I'm really hoping we
get to see more of them in season 6 but
because there's no actual footage from
season six in this teaser we'll just
have to speculate now there has been a
lot of news from the set yeah we're
probably going to get a tower of joy
flashback we might get other flashbacks
that's really the only one that I'm
counting on and no idea if that's going
to confirm our plus l equals J or not it
is going to be freaking awesome either
way now most of what this teaser focuses
on is stuff that's happening in Westeros
they have cast a number of younger
actors to play existing characters on
the show some of them who are currently
dead but I think they're doing is
they're going to do all the flashbacks
the george RR martin wrote in to dance
with dragons so if you want to read what
the Bloodraven is talking about george
RR martin actually wrote those scenes
and dance with dragons so that is the
book to reread if you want to learn more
brand stuff the big thing I feel like is
going to be missing with that arc is
cold hands not expecting any kind of
cold hands to show up on the TV show
think of him the way you would think of
Lady Stoneheart like there might be
characters with shades of cold hands but
I'm not expecting the actual cold hands
character let me know in the comments
though what do you guys think about this
teaser it isn't it so awesome that they
are not doing that site viral teaser
stuff that they did last year that was
so buggy that that did not work at all I
think the last time that they did a
teaser like this like a teaser with no
actual footage for the next season was
during season 3 like they released it in
the winter then the next spring there
released actual footage so maybe they
decided based on the reaction from last
year's teasers just to go back to the
old system like everybody is very
comfortable with like the teaser then
you get the actual trailers with big
footage during the spring what they
might do is because the vinyl series the
HBO is airing is going to pre see Game
of Thrones they might drop the actual
trailer during a vinyl broadcast for
those that are asking to it sounds like
Game of Thrones Season 6 is going to
premiere either late in April maybe
early May depending on whether there's a
break between the final finale in the
Game of Thrones season 6 premiere but
either way let me know what you guys
think about this teaser I know there's a
lot of jon snow in it I've already done
a Jon Snow teaser video they released
the image just kind of messing with our
heads a little so I'll have links for
that in the description if you want to
learn more about the Bloodraven in his
history in Westeros I'll put a link for
that too this is one of the best early
holiday presents ever I'm so happy and I
totally was not expecting it I almost
fell out of my chair congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Michael
masco you in a twenty dollar amazon gift
card please private message me on the
back end of my channel so i can get your
contact info engine just because this is
such a big deal i'm going to reboot the
giveaway extra fast I mean I'm still
doing a game of Thrones bonus video on
Sunday but all you have to do to enter
the giveaway is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video it'll just
be another twenty dollar amazon gift
card so what i'm going to do a Q&A video
for this on sunday so leave all your
questions in the comments so much
awesome stuff happening right now in
case you haven't seen it i did a Batman
vs Superman trailer last night you can
click here to watch that and you can
click here to learn all about the
Bloodraven in A Song of Ice and Fire
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you